nous sommes à éco mobile au lamentin un
lieu de vie une association
particulièrement dynamique qui existe
depuis onze ans sa vocation promouvoir
l'auto réparation d'objets pour éviter
la surproduction de déchets en
martinique à traversons ripert qui a
fait quatre ateliers sont proposés au
public pour réparer petit électroménager
informatique vélo ou même pour faire de
la couture ici 50% du personnel et un
service civique
ils sont sept pour sept salariés un
dosage savamment étudié pour offrir un
accompagnement personnalisé à chaque
jeune homme n'avait pas de métier tout
ça c'est là c'est là qu'on m'a mis et
j'aime bien
si la personne connue dans le vélo je
peux la prenons tout ça et s'il connaît
pas les pièces tout ça cela pourrait
aussi gilles lui se spécialise dans
l'informatique il est arrivé au terme de
ses huit mois de service civique et
s'apprête à signer un contrat parcours
emploi compétences de son propre aveu
s'il avait dû intégrer une entreprise au
lieu du service civique
il n'aurait certainement pas su
conserver son emploi je vois là service
civique un peu comme une couveuse
professionnelle c'est à dire que au lieu
d'un directement relancer vraiment de
professionnels on va être lancée dans un
monde professionnel qui adapte et déjà
en août je sois économies et on va
prendre la posture professionnelle au
fur et à mesure pour ensuite s'il le
faut lorsque les investisseurs qui finit
à voir au moins une base professionnelle
qui vont nous permettre de conserver un
emploi pour la suite et nous on a choisi
d'accompagner ces jeunes qui ont parfois
des bagages assez lourd et
malheureusement le palais porte
facilement parce que manque de diplôme
on manque d'expérience et on a on a fait
le choix de
d'accompagner tous ces petits parce que
c'est des bébés sa masse dvb quand il
arrive
mais très vite ils prennent leur place
il apporte énormément de choses parce
que trippant steve et tout ça ça va
l'aider pour son futur
selon les chiffres de l' agence du
service civique le nombre de volontaires
en martinique est passé de 241 en 2010 à
795 en 2016